thirty-two game winning streak Jame
Holzhauer James Holzhauer joins us on
the program did you watch last night
James I did you know I made this promise
to my kid that's when her dad finally
lost so she wouldn't be upset about it
she got a party the next day so we kind
of had to make sure she watched and I
still haven't planned the party so
hopefully I can wing it what was your
strategy uh well you know I just went
out there and tried to play my best game
you know and I ran up against a really
good opponents who hit the daily doubles
bet big on them and beat me you know
it's not mercifully much more to it than
that how did you keep it a secret you
know I honestly thought it was kind of a
fun surprise to spring on everyone like
you know we can advance I tell everyone
hey I'm going on Jeopardy but you know
it's more fun I think if they're
surprised along the way when these
things happen but this was February when
you shot the last episode last game I
was March 12 and did you have any
inkling that you were in trouble or you
know that you had a pretty good opponent
there at what point did you realize you
know this this could come to an end we
do a little practice in the morning and
she was clearly a very good on the
buzzer then but you know it's hard to
get a grip on anyone's threats of
knowledge at that point and you know I'd
say in the middle of the game it was
very clear that this is gonna be a tough
one and you know I better hit the dealer
doubles before she does didn't get there
and having done sports jeopardy and I
tell people that there is a rhythm to
buzzing in and once you get that rhythm
down it's such an advantage did you find
that that was the case yeah I think if
you look at my stats over the game so it
took me a few games to really warm up
but then I was kind of crushing it on
the buzzer for a while there so it makes
it even more impressive that a player
can come in cold and take me out there
was a lot of conspiracy theories out
there about you James did you did you
read these I read some of them you know
I think I try not to get into too many
of them but some of them were just funny
you know talking about me finding a way
to bet a million dollars against myself
some underground bookie this is how that
would be more valuable to me than
continuing to win on the show where I'm
taking 75 G's a half-hour yeah
did you lose on purpose yesterday let's
just get it on the record
oh I'm gonna say no you're going I'm
thinking maybe you know are you are you
setting yourself up as Jennings will be
the favorite you'll be the underdog
because he won more prize money won more
games and you meal I brought this up to
you last time a million dollar showdown
you and him and then we throw in
somebody else put it on prime-time and
make it an hour people are watching that
what do you think I do cut I do kind of
want to be like Floyd Mayweather and
just roll up to the sports book with a
bunch of money to bet on myself I don't
know I think that I've been announce it
before it it's taped for that to even be
possible and I don't think Nevada Gaming
allows setting on TV shows of this
juncture I will say my Twitter following
has grown exponentially in a bad day so
maybe the real conspiracy theory is that
I threw the game for that what are you
gonna do like can you can you do
something based off of this there's a
lot of people trying to hit me up with
some opportunities right now so I gotta
take a little while to sift through
those but yeah I think there there are
options what was your favorite answer
what was your favorite category if there
was one favorite answer was definitely
when I got to call back to my dr. Dre
interview that I had given the previous
month favorite category there's the
childís Bambino category about Babe
Ruth's antics even though I got one
wrong but you know the dr. Dre you took
a little bit of grief that he went with
people saying you mispronounced his name
oh yeah well you know I gave this
interview the months before about how my
dad memorized dr. Dre's name for the
crossword puzzle but he thought I was
pronounced dr. dree because you never
heard of him and so I you know I really
was hoping I could bring it on that
question to make this call back when I
do a lot of the people at home wouldn't
understand what's the one that you got
wrong that is gonna stay with you for a
while um I don't know that any
particular answer is going to stay with
me you know I really wish I there was a
key time in yesterday's game where I got
a question right and took control of the
board and she had a Daily Double on the
next clue but you know it happens I know
I was going to lose eventually I could
have done a lot worse than to lose this
clearly stellar player
did you know that Alex was undergoing
treatment did you know he was sick yeah
this was actually the first episode that
taped after he went public with that
announcement so that was why we featured
my daughters get well card and show
yesterday he's a tough guy man and I
tell people how easy he makes that look
and it is not easy at all hosting
jeopardy I was incredible you know I
think he had he had taped about eight
episodes that week before they mentioned
to us that he was sick and you know I
wouldn't have noticed anything different
if nobody had said anything it's such a
professional well James congratulations
a lot of fun and hopefully there's
something that you can jump on and
extend this and maybe there is a
showdown at ventually with you and Ken
Jennings okay thank you Dan thank you
James it's James whole summer the former
jeopardy champ they won over two million
dollars won 32 consecutive games yeah
there was a lot of conspiracy theorists
out there know that you know the
category that the winner had was
Shakespeare and Jesus Shakespeare she
wrote a thesis on Shakespeare you know
were they setting this up did he throw
it why did he only bet you know thirteen
hundred ninety nine dollars and you know
he was everything was strategy you know
strategy with him so I don't think it
was you know hey I'm just tired I'm
gonna go home I mean it's pretty good
pretty good run there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]